S
A POTENTIAL MODEL FOR THE U.S.
WHEN IT COMES TO FIGHTING
SKEPTICISM ABOUT VACCINES.
IN FRANCE, PROOF OF VACCINATION
IS NOW REQUIRED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT MACRON LAUNCHED THE
HEALTH PASS AT THE START OF
SUMMER AS CASES STARTED RISING
AGAIN.
AND THIS WAS A MOVE YOU MAY
RECALL THAT LED TO WEEKS OF
THESE LARGE-SCALE PROTESTS, BUT
WOULD THIS WORK IN THE U.S.?
CNN'S MELISSA BELL IS LIVE FOR
US IN PARIS WITH MORE.
THIS IS -- IS THIS A CASE STUDY?
THAT'S THE QUESTION, MELISSA.
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, BRIANNA,
YOU HAVE BEEN TALKING THIS
MORNING ABOUT THAT SENSE OF
FRUSTRATION THAT YOU HEARD LAST
NIGHT FROM JOE BIDEN.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HEARD A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO FROM THE
FRENCH PRESIDENT AS WELL.
HE, TOO, WAS COMING UP AGAINST
THAT WALL OF VACCINE HESITANCY
AND HE KNEW THAT HE NEEDED TO
OVERCOME IT.
SO, FAR MORE AGGRESSIVE STRATEGY
FOR TRYING TO CONVINCE PEOPLE TO
GET VACCINATED.
AND I THINK WHAT IT HAS SHOWN,
BRIANNA, IS WHILE THERE MAY BE A
HARD CORE OF PEOPLE WHO WILL
NEVER GET VACCINATED, THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE HESITANT CAN
ACTUALLY BE CONVINCED.
IT WAS THE PUSH BACK IN JULY
THAT MADE ALL THE DIFFERENCE.
>> Translator: WE'RE EXTENDING
THE USE OF THE HEALTH PASS TO
PUSH AS MANY OF YOU AS POSSIBLE
TO GO AND GET VACCINATED.
>> Reporter: WITHIN 24 HOURS,
ALMOST A MILLION APPOINTMENTS
HAD BEEN BOOKED.
WITH THE HEALTH PASS, WHICH
SHOWS WHETHER YOU'VE BEEN
VACCINATED OR HAVE HAD A PCR
TEST WITHIN 72 HOURS, SUDDENLY
NEEDED TO ENTER RESTAURANTS,
MUSEUMS, CAFES AND BARS AND NOW
EXTENDED TO EMPLOYEES OF ANY
BUSINESS THAT SERVES THE PUBLIC.
>> THEY SAY YOU HAVE THE CHOICE
BUT YOU DON'T REALLY.
IT'S EITHER YOU GET VACCINATED
OR YOU PAY FOR YOUR TEST.
SO, IS IT REALLY A CHOICE?
>> Reporter: ANNA SAYS SHE
WASN'T GOING TO GET VACCINATED.
LIKE 60% OF THOSE POLLED DURING
FRANCE'S SECOND LOCKDOWN IN
DECEMBER.
FOR A LONG TIME, THE UNITED
STATES WAS AHEAD OF FRANCE IN
TERMS OF THE PROPORTION OF THE
POPULATION THAT HAD RECEIVED AT
LEAST ONE DOSE.
THEN IN JULY, MACRON TOOK A
GAMBLE.
JUST AS VACCINATION CENTERS WERE
EMPTYING AS VACCINE HESITANCY
KICKED IN AND FRENCH HOSPITALS
WERE BEING OVERRUN BY THE DELTA
VARIANT.
>> TOOK THE RISK TO SAY I WILL
MAKE THE LIFE OF THE
UNVACCINATED VERY DIFFICULT,
WHICH IS VERY, VERY, VERY
DANGEROUS STATEMENT.
>> Reporter: PROTESTS FOLLOWED.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CAME ON JULY
31st, JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AFTER MACRON MADE HIS SPEECH.
ACROSS FRANCE, 204,000 PEOPLE
TOOK TO THE STREETS ACCORDING TO
THE INTERIOR MINISTRY.
BUT FULL OF NOISE THAT VERY SAME
DAY NUMBER OF PEOPLE WERE
QUIETLY GETTING AN INJECTION.
THE REASON SAYS THIS FRENCH
LAWMAKER THAT MOST PEOPLE
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE ALTERNATIVE
WAS YET ANOTHER LOCKDOWN.
>> Translator: IT WAS SAYING TO
THE FRENCH, SHE SAYS, THAT IF
YOU'RE VACCINATED YOU CAN LIVE
LIKE YOU USED TO.
THIS HEALTH PASS WILL GIVE YOU
YOUR FREEDOM BACK.
NOW FRANCE HAS ONE OF THE BEST
VACCINATION RATES IN THE WORLD.
OVER 62%.
AND DESPITE THE SPREAD OF THE
DELTA VARIANT, HOSPITAL
ADMISSIONS HAVE GONE DOWN.
>> THE DELTA VARIANT GOES FASTER
BUT ENOUGH PEOPLE ARE VACCINATED
IT'S A BALANCE BETWEEN BEING
MORE CONTAGIOUS AND NEEDING MORE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IMMUNIZED.
>> Reporter: HE WAS ABLE TO ACT
AT A NATIONAL LEVEL WITH STRONG
EXECUTIVE POWERS AND SOLID
PARLIAMENTARY MAJORITY NONE OF
WHICH JOE BIDEN HAS ON HIS SIDE,
BUT THE FRENCH MODEL DOES SHOW
THAT WITH SOME ENCOURAGEMENT
EVEN THE VACCINE HESITANT CAN BE
CONVINCED THAT IN THE
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES OF A
PANDEMIC, INDIVIDUAL LIBERTIES
MUST END WHERE COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY BEGINS.
BRIANNA, EMMANUEL MACRON HAD A
BUNCH OF TOOLS AT HIS DISPOSAL,
AS YOU JUST HEARD, THAT JOE
BIDEN DOESN'T.
WHAT IT DOES SHOW IS THAT LITTLE
PUSH CAN MAKE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE, BRIANNA.
>> YEAH.
AS YOUR FIRST PERSON IN THAT
STORY SAID, IS IT REALLY A
CHOICE?
MELISSA BELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH
LIVE FOR US IN PARIS.
>>> BACK WITH US NOW DR. SANJAY
GUPTA AND DR. RICHARD BESSER.
RICH, IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
YOU ALLUDED TO THIS BEFORE AND I
WANT YOU TO TALK ABOUT IT MORE,
ABOUT YOUR OWN PERSONAL
EVOLUTION HERE AS SOMEONE DEEP
INTO THE PUBLIC HEALTH SECTOR,
YOU WENT FROM THINKING AND
HOPING THAT EDUCATION ON
VACCINES WOULD DO THE TRICK.
BUT NOW --
>> YEAH --
>> NOW YOU THINK THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE.
YOU'RE SEEING IT IN FRANCE.
YOU THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
THAN JUST TELLING PEOPLE AND
EXPLAINING TO PEOPLE WHY IT'S
BENEFICIAL.
>> I DO.
AND I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD GIVE
UP ON TRYING TO MEET PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE, UNDERSTANDING
THEIR CONCERNS AND ADDRESSING
THOSE.
BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT THE DECLINES
THAT WE WERE SEEING AT THE END
OF JUNE, THE BEGINNING OF JULY,
THE HOPE THAT WE WERE GOING TO
COME INTO A FALL AND SEE VERY
LOW LEVELS THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO GET BACK TO OUR LIVES, THAT
HASN'T HAPPENED.
AND IT HASN'T HAPPENED LARGELY
BECAUSE OF THE NEW VARIANT, THE
DELTA VARIANT THAT IS SO WIDELY
TRANSMISSIBLE.
AND TO ME, THAT'S A GAME
CHANGER.
IT'S SAYING TO ME IF WE WANT TO
GET BACK TO OUR LIVES F WE WANT
TO GET OUR ECONOMY GOING F WE
WANT TO KEEP CHILDREN IN SCHOOL
LEARNING, WHICH IS WHERE THEY
SHOULD BE, WE NEED TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED.
AND AS A PEDIATRICIAN, I
EXPERIENCED THIS BIG TIME IN
TERMS OF SCHOOL VACCINE
MANDATES.
WITH WHERE I HAVE A LOT OF
PATIENTS A LOT OF PARENTS WHO
MAY HAVE CONCERN ABOUT VACCINE,
BUT THOSE CONCERNS ARE NOT
OUTWEIGHED BY THEIR DESIRE TO
HAVE THEIR KIDS IN SCHOOL
LEARNING.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE HEARING,
SEEING IN FRANCE, ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SOCIETY FULLY,
ARE VACCINATED CAN HAVE A BIG
IMPACT AND SO WHEN WE'RE HEARING
THE PRESIDENT YESTERDAY CALLING
ON VACCINE REQUIREMENTS FOR
LARGE GATHERINGS, FOR ARENAS,
FOR PEOPLE COMING TOGETHER, IN
ORDER TO DO THAT AND DO IT
EFFECTIVELY, YOU DON'T WANT
SOMEONE WITH A FLASHLIGHT
LOOKING AT A VACCINE CARD.
YOU WANT TO HAVE SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE EASY AND SOMETHING LIKE
THAT VACCINE PASSPORT IS A GOOD
APPROACH TO MAKE IT PLAUSIBLE
FOR PEOPLE TO RESTRICT ENTRY OF
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T VACCINATED.
>> I WOULD TAKE SOMEONE WITH A
FLASHLIGHT LOOKING AT VACCINE
CARDS.
I DON'T SEE IT EVER.
WE HAD MICHAEL SMERCONISH ON
YESTERDAY WHEN WE GOT OUR
VACCINE CARDS, I DIDN'T LAMINATE
MINE, STILL HAVEN'T, I THOUGHT I
SHOULD HAVE BECAUSE I THOUGHT I
WOULD SHOW IT PLACES AND
IDENTIFY ONLY HAD TO SHOW IT A
COUPLE PLACES ONCE AT MY KID'S
SCHOOL TO GET IN AND ONCE HERE
AT WORK.
I WONDER IF YOU THINK THAT
SHOULD BE MORE WIDESPREAD AND IF
YOU SHOULD HAVE TO DO THAT TO
GET ON SAY A PLANE OR A TRAIN TO
TRAVEL?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, FIRST
QUESTION, YOU KNOW, JUST ABOUT
THE IDEA OF HAVING SOME SORT OF
NATIONAL SYSTEM LIKE A PASSPORT
OF SORTS, YES.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
I GOT MY CARD HERE.
IT'S KIND OF AMAZING TO ME THAT
ALL THIS TALK THAT WE'RE HAVING
RESOLVES AROUND SOMETHING THAT
LOOKS LIKE THIS AND PEOPLE DON'T
ALWAYS CARRY IT WITH THEM.
THEY'RE HARDLY EVER ASKED TO
SHOW IT, AS YOU POINT OUT.
IT'S KIND OF REMARKABLE AND
RIGHT AWAY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BASICALLY SAID
WE'RE NOT GOING TO CREATE A
FEDERAL SORT OF DATA BASE.
PASSPORT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY SAID SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO.
THERE'S STILL NO SORT OF FEDERAL
DATA BASE OR PASSPORT.
I THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE A HARD TIME
SORT OF NAVIGATING THAT WHOLE
SYSTEM.
I THINK THAT -- I CAN'T
REMEMBER -- WHAT WAS THE SECOND
PART OF YOUR QUESTION?
APOLOGIES.
>> FOR PLANES AND TRAINS.
I'LL BE HONEST, I WAS ON A TRAIN
YESTERDAY FOR WORK AND I'M
SITTING THERE WITH 40 OF MY
CLOSEST FRIENDS GOING, HELLO.
WHO IS WHO?
>> NO, I KNOW.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
WE'VE LOOKED A LOT AT THE WHOLE
AVIATION JUST INTERSTATE TRAVEL
AS WELL IN TERMS OF THESE
MANDATES AND WHAT WE HEAR IS
BASICALLY THERE HASN'T BEEN REAL
SIGNIFICANT SPREAD WITHIN
AIRLINE TRAVEL.
THAT'S TRUE.
I THINK BECAUSE OF THE
FILTRATION, BECAUSE OF THE MASK
REQUIREMENTS AND ALL THAT, IT
DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
BUT, I THINK THE FLIP SIDE OF IT
IS THAT THIS IS ANOTHER CARROT
POTENTIALLY, ANOTHER TOOL TO GET
PEOPLE VACCINATED.
IF YOU WANT TO FLY, YOU HAVE TO
BE VACCINATED.
THEY WEREN'T READY TO MAKE THAT
JUMP YET AS PART OF THE
SIX-POINT PLAN THAT WAS ROLLED
OUT YESTERDAY.
BUT I THINK THAT WILL BE ANOTHER
THING THAT WOULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
PLANES AND TRAINS, ANYTHING WITH
INTERSTATE TRAVEL, IF WE'RE
TRYING TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE VACCINATED
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE, THAT
WOULD BE ANOTHER IMPOR